i like i sometimes like when i hear
these arguments
i'm like i don't even understand how
grown adults are like talking like this
like
grown ass like men and women are making
these laws yeah
you know like i'm like how are adults
like grown like letting
young young people and even high
schoolers yeah i saw this thing where it
was like a high school track and they
let men in like compete against the
women and track that's what i said i'm
like how are adults
letting this happen
i'm like cognitively that no it's just
like common sense that
i'm gonna just bring up the swimming
picture one more time because like like
we said earlier if they're if there
would wasn't no difference first of all
you wouldn't need to specify between men
and women just be people just be people
yeah and
yeah there wouldn't be no separation
between men and women's sports
period if there wasn't
a disadvantage and if
there wasn't that if there wasn't
something that needed a separation
and
now
there's something that wasn't
popular back in the day when they did
make the
men and women sports that are now coming
into it
and it's like
oh just because you throw
women's behind trans okay yeah go ahead
it's like
but we're forgetting that there's a
separation for a reason and there's a
separate and there's and we have that
separation because of
these things that qualify you as a man
and these things that qualify you as a
woman and if it was equal like men would
join them were women trans oh my gosh
biological women would join the men's
league and kick ass but they don't you
only see that happening one way
and oh my gosh it's just like i i just i
i hear some of these people like talk
that make the laws
that make the law
do you see that do you see that clip
where the girl was like
the girl was like that's a dude it's at
the swim meet and then the guy that
worked at the ncaas was like well are
you a doctor and she's like i'm not a
vet but i know a dog when i see one
wow
she's like i don't need a vet like
yo
and that's even when you sent me that
clip where that where that gra guy was
like well you're on hormones for a year
you go through these changes and i'm
like
i don't need a degree to just tell you
this is crazy like this is nonsense that
was the case i can't tell you the
science i have no idea what they do to
their body
but like come on if that was the case
then everybody would just be
born
just be born and we'd just be
be born and then you can choose
yeah
you just choose do you want to take
testosterone for the rest of your life
or do you want to take action for the
rest of your life and then once you take
that
that identifies you as a woman that
identifies you as a man and if that if
that is the key factor then what what
would be the point of us having
having boobs having a uterus having the
i don't know if i could say
the other word
the v word
you could just say that
a little kid or cat
there wouldn't be a point
of
any of that
for us to like have those things as a
woman if the deciding factor was
estrogen
and testosterone
yeah it's it's having kids yeah that's
what and then they'll use the stupid
argument well some women can't have kids
yeah but they still have the biological
things to have kids if this is a genetic
like mutation and then and then
yeah and then the other argument they'll
say is like
women like well you're stronger than
it's not all men that'll dominate it's
like some men am i like like i could
still out i can outlift a lot like i'm
strong i'm like
i can outlift a lot of guys
but my brother who hasn't worked out in
five years can out bench me yeah
and that's just that's just it like
i bet you my little brother that hasn't
lifted weights maybe
more than a month in his life could
probably
outbench me or probably lift weights
more than me just because
he's a man and it's just like that's
like that's like saying like teenagers
versus adults
like because some teenage like let's say
we do a 13 year old division should 13
year olds play against like 21 year olds
because some 13 year olds can
compete with the 21 yeah and that's like
that's the exception there's there's
some
some kids that can do that but
you can't take the exception
and then group everybody in that
exception and it's just like well i'm
i'm not that exceptional i can't play
with no 21 year old like i want to play
with people my age on a level playing
field and do you feel like as a big it's
like like because we're we're both
centers right you're you're kind of
centered
like i think
it hurts us more because like i would
have no opportunity at all competing
against i'm not tall yeah
uh trans women yeah i wouldn't have no
like i'm not gonna lie i've played
against
guys in like i've played a game i play
against guys like sometimes yeah and
there's just certain things that i just
wouldn't even post up because i'm like
what's the point of posting up against a
guy that's like six foot five yeah is
there really a point he's gonna block
the sh yeah
what's the point so
i talk a lot of [ __ ] to dudes too like i
always tell them
i i always say i can beat them in
one-on-one even if i know i'm damn well
i can't i don't i'm like
like completely change the way i play
like i'll shoot a lot because i don't
know i don't want to like get i'm not
trying to yeah yeah
pull up like i shoot more threes than
i've ever shot in my life
and i used to beat my last boyfriend in
one-on-one all the time but it was also
because he was really overweight that
was the only reason that like as soon as
it was so humbling because he lost like
a bunch of weight when we were together
and as soon as he like got to a certain
way i i couldn't win anymore no it was
just over with
dang
that's crazy and he he played like what
a year or two of high school bat i
played in college i played overseas like
barely still counts
so for so for us to be able to
compete with men they have to be
physically
lesser than us
like and like just out of shape for us
to be able to yeah we're shorter or
the trans women that are going into
these leagues are actually athletes but
whilst they were a man so like yeah
they're like physically fit already and
then they're going into the league oh
well they're transitioning and then
they're going into our leagues but
they're still like got the
physicality of a man they've been
draining their whole life yeah so it's
like
yeah
and then it becomes dangerous as a
society because we stop like accepting
what reality is yeah then we start like
i i identify as a child put me in pre-k
yeah
like i know i have a freaking taboo or a
day in my life when these grown adults
are like i identify as a baby
we went like wearing diapers growing
adults wearing diapers and the
it's just it's like you're you're how 40
we're in a diaper
eating baby food drinking out of a
bottle
if you don't look yourself in the mirror
and get yourself get your tail to work
or something you are not an infant
anymore let's bring back bullying
no i swear to god because i feel like
the older generation just bullied each
other out of this [ __ ] they really did
they were you i was bullied it was good
for me it was annoying as hell
sometimes i need to learn to shut the
[ __ ] up
we're breathing
but yeah
i can understand that it's just
ugh jesus
like all right i could identify as like
native american give me a scholarship
elizabeth
and
they're
like
um
and i feel like it's so touchy now that
people don't go into like looking into
that so you could say that you could say
i'm native american and have all the
information you you need you could have
like i think it's is it 15 you need to
be
native american it's something there's a
certain percentage you need and it's not
you don't have to be full-blooded you
can you just need to be part of a tribe
so in the states there's um
in the states there's uh territories in
um
some states and that used to be native
land and so
if you are native american and if you're
from any tribe you can get a scholarship
at certain schools because you are
native american because they're on they
get a lot they get a lot of like native
american scholarships are like and so um
essentially they
it's like
everybody just takes your word for it i
could say i'm uh
i'm a quarter or 50 cherokee you
wouldn't question it because i know oh
this is where this land is this is where
this is i i researched myself and so i'm
able to like convince you
that i'm it like okay
give me my money and i feel like it's
got to that to where people just don't
question it they just take their words
and people can
lie
just so easily and it's just like
even even this dude do we think leah
thomas is really trans like
yo i had that thought i had i'm not like
discrediting her but i had that thought
cause essentially
essentially it's a cheat code like if
i'm 400 something in immensely and i'm
like nobody's going to question me if
i'm really a trans woman no one's going
to ask me for if i'm taking this and i
can be in cahoots with my doctor and say
like if someone asks you if i'm taking
estrogen just say yeah and i'm like i'm
gonna go compete as a woman in the sport
and
dominate and then i'm gonna go to the
olympics and make money
from being a trans woman but i'm really
not
and it
is like i don't like she just thinks why
all this looks like a dude like i don't
see fake boobs okay
nothing
it's like a dude in in a swimsuit
like like what long hair like what the
i almost think it looks more like a dude
that one
this one
so is that
is that before and after i don't
know
yale trans swimmer beats fellow trans
athlete
i don't i